in the last video we figured out what
you know how many different ways could i
don't know five people
five people
sit in three chairs you know so for
example if this is chair one this is
chair two this is chair three we said
well in chair one we could put five
people no one's
sitting down then there's only going to
be four people left so we could put four
different people in chair two
and then there would be three people
left that we could put in chair three so
the total combination the total uh
permutations the different ways that
people could sit in the different chairs
if we cared about the order
if we cared about which chair they were
sitting down in it would be five times
four times three
and another way of thinking about that 5
times 4 times 3 that's the same thing
that equals
5 times 4
times 3 times 2 times 1
over
what
over 2 times 1
right and that's the same thing as 5
factorial
over 2 factorial
and now where does this 2 come from
how is 2 related to the 5 and 3
what's the difference between the two so
this is the same thing
this is equal to
5 factorial
over
minus 3
factorial and that in general is how we
figure out how many permutations can uh
in how many permutations can five things
place themselves or be placed into three
positions
the general formula is and we learned
this in the last video and i will switch
colors
now if we want to put n things
into i don't know k positions
and k has to be less than or equal to n
well actually it doesn't have to but for
our purposes right now assume it is
because our formula might break down if
it weren't
and that equals
n
factorial
over
n minus k factorial i always find this
harder to memorize than just thinking
about the spots and just saying oh well
you know five people five of the things
could be here and then once one thing is
here there's four possibilities left and
then there's three possibilities left so
i just kind of take the first
the way i think of it i take the first k
terms of the
of the
of the n factorial or in this case i
take the first three terms of the five
factorial one two three five times four
times three that's how i think of
permutations
so what if this is great if we cared you
know
if if we let's say these are people
a
b
c d
e so these are the five people are going
to sit in the chairs this is great if we
really cared if we wanted to count
a the permutation a b c
as different from the permutation
a c b
as different from the permutation i
don't know
b
a c as different from the permutation
c a
and it will because remember when we did
this we actually cared about where
they're sitting and in the previous
video i actually you know we count we
double counted everything because it
cares if it matters if person a is in
seat one and person b is in c2 and then
if they switch we recount it right this
is where they switch but what if we
didn't care about that what if we didn't
care who's in what seat we just wanted
to know how many different ways can the
five people sit down
right so we want to count all the
situations where
people person a b and c are sitting down
as essentially one situation right we
don't care who's you know sitting in
which chair we just care that those are
the three people sitting down that's the
set the subset of the people sitting
down and so the question then becomes
not how many different permutations or
how many different ways can the people
sit down
the
the question becomes how many subsets of
three can we take out of a set of five
and that's essentially and i know i'm
kind of
jumping up around a little bit but
that's essentially what a combination is
a combination is a permutation where you
don't care about the order
so how do we figure it out well when we
figured out the permutations using this
formula
we counted for example we counted abc
acb bac
bca and let's see there should be two
more combinations two more permutations
c
a b
and c
b a we counted all six of these as
different permutations but in our
combinations we're going to want to this
is all essentially the same
the same combination because we don't
care about the order right so for any
three
different people that are in these seats
there's actually going to be six
permutations that we're counting when we
do the permutations so if we want the
combinations we'll just divide by the
number of ways we can rearrange three
people into three seats that's
essentially what we did here so how many
different ways can you raise three
people into three seats well this is
kind of another permutation problem
right the first seat you could put you
know three different people the second
seat you put two different people in the
last seat well there's only one person
left
so it equals three factorial which is
equal to six
right this is equal to
three fact three factorial which is
equal to six
hope i'm not confusing that what i'm
just trying to say is when you did a
permutation we counted all of the
different orders of how uh
of how people could arrange themselves
and what i'm saying now well how many
different ways can people arrange
themselves well it's going to be the
number of places factorial right because
you know if we have three people in
three spots or let's say four people in
four spots the fourth spot can have four
people the second spot can have three
and so forth the the third spot could
have two and the last spot will only
have one right so it's it's the number
of spots factorial is how many
permutations we're counting when we have
just the same people just they're just
playing musical chairs in the exact same
seats so in order to figure out the
combination so if we wanted to say how
many people
let's say if we had five people how many
different groups of three
can be seated and we don't want to
double we don't want to more than double
count i don't know what the word is for
counting something six times
well it's just going to be the same
thing as the permutation
divided by
all of the extra counting we do we'll
just divide by the number of ways that
three people can arrange themselves in
three seats and that's three factorial
right so in general if we and i hope i'm
making sense maybe i'll do a couple more
examples in other videos and definitely
request it if you think this is extra
confusing
so in general if we say
what are the different ways that n
things can be chosen
or the number of combinations that n
things can be chosen into sets of
r where r is less than or equal to n
it's equal to the number of permutations
you could create of putting n things
into r spots
divided by
r factorial
right because we're gonna we're gonna
we're going to divide by the number of
ways the r spots themselves could be
rearranged because we don't want to
count those as extra and so if we go
back to this formula up here well this
was a k but now we're saying it's an r
this is the same thing as
so the permutations was
n
factorial
over
n minus r factorial and now we're
dividing everything by r factorial
so that equals so let me just write this
and we could this is often written as
n choose r
another way it's written is n choose r
this is called the binomial coefficient
and we'll do a whole series of modules
on that as well because this actually
shows up in other fie in polynomial
expansion when you take polynomials to
powers
but this is equal to
n factorial
over r factorial
divided by n minus r factorial
you could memorize this you know it's
useful if you want to do things quickly
on tests but it's very important to
think about where it came from
right the n factorial over the n minus r
factorial this is just the permutation
and how and what is that well that was
just the first r
um i guess you could call it the first r
factors the the r largest factors of n
factorial that's all that is and then we
do when we do the combinations we divide
it by r factorial because we want to
divide it by all the different
arrangements that the people could seat
themselves in in our seats or the balls
could be placed in our cups
so in this situation if we want to know
how many different groups of three can
be selected from five people or from
five letters it's going to be five
factorial
over
three factorial
times five minus three factorial
and that's five times three times two
times one
over
three factorial is just six we'll put
that aside for a second divided by this
is two factorial two times one so notice
the perm this is the permutation part
right here this this term just gets rid
of the two lowest factors you get five
times three
five times three oh sorry there's a four
five times four times three right which
is the number of permutations and then
we divide by
6 because
we get 6 permutations for really every
combination
maybe that confused you but anyway so we
get 5 times 4 times 3 divided by 6
and that's what 5 times
12 divided by 6
which is equal to
5 times 2 which is equal there's 10
possible ways that we could take sets of
3 from a group of 5 things
see you in the next video